bonjour bonjour
notre invité le policier que vous êtes
président du voka rôle et on est bavard
par les
gendarmes du président des centristes et
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
l'interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale présentée par
christiane berton du groupe la dépêche
aujourd'hui encore yann montjoux hervé
morin bonjour on va parler de
l'actualité avant de parler des
élections législatives hervé morin est
d'abord la police tu sais ce qu a tweeté
jean luc mélenchon après un contrôle de
police à l'issue duquel la passagère du
véhicule a été tué par des tirs
policiers est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec elisabeth bornes qui juge ces
propos très choquant
mélenchon c'est l'outrance c'est la
haine
incarner c'est la fragmentation à
l'infini du pays et c'est l'effondrement
économique et social du pays c'est
géant bleu on évoquait ce avant de
rentrer en studio on sait que le parti
socialiste puisse avoir vendu son âme au
point de s'associer à mélenchon jeu
quand on regarde son projet il faut
juste se dire mais tout ça est
absolument surréalistes francs un seul
exemple
il est pour l'effacement de la dette
mais la dette voulait face et comment
vous l'effacer en dix ans la banque
centrale européenne qui détient
l'essentiel de la dette française
et budget veut dire quoi ça veut dire
quoi les concerts de l'euro concret sa
monnaie
êtes-vous passé il ya des gens qui vont
prêter à la france si la france dit je
n'aurai pas ma tête ça veut dire qu en
vérité je te propose mélenchon c'est
l'amérique latine le chili l'argentine
c'est de dire les plus pauvres qui
seraient frappés parce que le plus riche
is débrouille toujours dans ce genre de
cas de figure les plus pauvres qui
seraient frappés géré j'ai tout est
ainsi qu'à et donc dire quand il dit il
faut travailler moins pour donner plus
de travail mais le problème c'est pas le
plus de travail le problème s'est trouvé
des françaises et des français capables
de de travailler dans les services
publics de travailler dans le secteur
privé y a pas un secteur qu'elle n'y a
pas une pénurie massive de main d'oeuvre
la question c'est de retour à l'emploi
c'est pas la division du travail et la
réduction du travail lance tout et
n'importe quoi voyons ce texte est dit
qu'il ya un problème de maintien de
l'ordre en france vous partagez pas son
point de vue non mais vous pouvez pas
revendiquer comme il le dit
d'être le premier ministre
aucun doute qu'ils seront pas les
français sont même si là nous paie ce ca
river oui oui majoritaire à l'assemblée
il le serait pas seront pas majoritaires
bon n'y a aucun doute là-dessus j'allais
les carrés est beaucoup trop grand
imaginez comment pouvez vous être à la
tête du pays en quelque sorte c'est ce
serait une cohabitation est donc
l'article 20 de la constitution
retrouvait tout son sens du gouvernement
détermine et conduit la politique de la
nation bien et le premier dirige
l'action du gouvernement
comment pourri brut le premier de la
france quand vous discréditer ceux qui
sont chargés de faire respecter la loi
comment après chaque chacun chaque chaka
mérite une analyse judiciaire une
information judiciaire qui est ouverte
il ya une enquête s'il doit y avoir des
sanctions de thierry champion mais mais
mais prenons les sens dans ce sens
prenons les choses en ce sens qu'on ne
sont pas à dire les policiers s'en sont
des assassins comme
sujets d'actualité hier il ya une
manifestation assez importante de
soignants dans plusieurs villes de
france
première question comment à votre avis
on en est arrivé là alors qu emmanuel
macron depuis cinq ans dit que la santé
est une des priorités de ce gouvernement
cinq ans plus tard encore des
manifestations
bah écoutez c'est la question faut il
que vous posiez à ce qu'ils monnayent
d'appartenir à la majorité clairement
c'est une succion situation structurelle
majeure - quand je discute avec le
personnel soignant on assiste très
clairement il faut se le dire un
effondrement de l'hôpital un
effondrement avec des départs massifs
et donc si on n'arrête pas l'hémorragie
tout de suite dans quel état sera le
combat ne fait plus rare est le premier
élément c'est de redonner du sens c'est
de redonner de l'humanité les soignants
vous dise maintenant on est quasiment on
parle entre collègues avec des textes et
auprès des services à côté pour moi il
est plus est ces communautés humaines
qui était au service de la santé et du
soigne et du malade donc il ya déjà ça
il ya redonner du sens
redonnez
ils ont décidé de soignants quand on
décide d'être soignants c'est qu'on aime
les autres c'est qu'on a envie de rendre
service à 7 et ceux qui sont en
situation de fragilité donc il faut
redonner bien entendu 1 il faut
améliorer la rémunération faire en sorte
que on redonne à ces métiers de
l'attractivité et puis ensuite il ya
toutes les solutions que qu'on connaît
c'est comment on intègre l'articulation
entre la médecine de ville et les
urgences comment entre les jauger
urgences et des services hospitaliers
comment on augmente assez massivement
les effectifs je prends ma région j'ai
décidé d'augmenter de 800 le nombre de
formation d'infirmière et d'éducateurs
spécialisés j'ai décidé d'augmenter de
plusieurs centaines d formation
d'aides-soignants mais tout est à
reprendre jusque là je suis moins région
obligés de financer les instituts de
formation soit un fermier c'est à dire
que je suis en train de reconstruire des
instituts de formation de soins
infirmiers dont je n'ai pas la
responsabilité tellement ils sont dans
un état lamentable faire que quand vous
dites un jeune
allait faire ce métier la première
expression de la nation à l'égard ce
métier c'est d'avoir des établissements
qui sont dans un état absolument
lamentable dans lequel vous dites mais
comment puis-je avoir comment peut-on me
dire que j'ai un beau métier quand on
déjà des structures de formation qui
sont dans un état absolument lamentable
nous ont mis 50 millions de royan la
jambe ont donc il faut jeu je suis la
seule région française à avoir mis de
l'argent à au c ur de la santé nous
avons mis quasiment autant que l'état
200 millions d'euros quand l'état met
240 millions dans la région je vais donc
dans chaque structure hospitalière à
l'hôpital de lisieux qui est un des
grands hôpitaux de la région normandie
vous avez du chatterton dans le service
dans les services pour éviter que la
flotte soit dans ce soit dans les
chambres il y à des hôpitaux dans lequel
vous avez une douche par étage vous avez
des hôpitaux dont l'état est comparable
ceux des pays les plus pauvres des pays
d'europe centrale orientale m'ont
insulté personne dans
est-ce que c'est une team tuer la
mission flash c'est pas au giallo
diagnostic tout le monde le connaît faut
arrêter se raconter des histoires le
seul problème c'est qu'on va être durant
l'été avec des tas de services qui vont
fermer parce qu'il n'y a pas de jeu
j'aurais bien dans mon lit et services
d'urgence ont déjà eu locaux déjà été
malheureusement fermé l'année dernière
et on est face à un tel
ou tel sous-effectif que le risque c'est
d'avoir énormément de services qui ferme
durant l'été et donc j'imagine que la
mission flash c'était en sorte que
chaque hôpital on essaie de trouver la
solution pour tenir durant l'été voilà
bon mais c'est pas ça dont on a besoin
un besoin ce qui est des mesures de
revalorisation de transformation du
modèle hospitalier revoir la
tarification l'activité etc etc sur le
pouvoir d'achat préoccupation là aussi
majeures des français né à berne a
annoncé hier qu'une aide serait versée à
la rentrée pour les ménages les plus
modestes afin de faire face à la hausse
générale des prix est ce que vous saluer
cette mesure est est ce que le fait
qu'elle soit ciblé cette réponse ciblée
la bonne bouffe oui enfin sauf que
à quand l adie sert à rien dit qu'on
gère d'ailleurs c'est à ce qui est assez
incroyable c'est l'absence de sens de
souffle de vision du pays à cinq ans si
jamais vu ça quoi enfin il est
incroyable c'est qu'on a pris on a un
public qui fait une interview on ne tire
rien on a un premier ministre qui est
inexistant mais derrière tout ça il ya
un sujet très simple c'est la
composition d'un gouvernement c'est pas
un gouvernement c'est quoi ce sont des
conseillers techniques c'est un cabinet
c'est le cabinet du président cc rien
d'autre et et regarder la composition du
gouvernement c'est incroyable j'ai fait
cet exercice
est ce qu'il ya une figure où un élu de
bretagne pains depuis qu'alain jean yves
le drian est reparti est ce qu'il ya
quelqu'un de nouvelles aquitaine ou
d'occitanie c'est vrai que ces
dirigeants qui comptent pas du tout en
france toulouse montpellier bordeaux
l'industrie de défense du slow réussit
pas vous dites en provence alpes côte
d'azur il doit y en avoir puisque il ya
eu tous les grands féodaux de 2,2 de ne
prendre ce cas pourquoi des sur fond
rejoint emmanuel macron pas qu'est-ce
que vous remontez en bourgogne pas vous
allez en grand test l'alsace la lorraine
pas c'est donc un haka bis et c'est un
gouvernement de l'autre soir avec des
polytechniciens et des politiques
chiliens alors le gouvernement de la
france en effet pas le gouvernement des
provinces mais la situation c'est bon
d'avoir des élus qu'ils soient
réellement des hommes politiques parce
que ça métier qu'on est meilleur à 50
ans qu'on l'état 35 et c'est bon d'avoir
bien on a quand même une ligier logement
qui a expliqué que le pavillon et la
maison individuelle c'était fini enfin
quand on ose quand on a quand on est
capable de dire de telles conneries
pardon lui à dire ça prouve à quel point
vous ne connaissez pas la france et
l'ariège la manche les vosges la
seine-saint-denis les problèmes sont pas
les mêmes justement dans cette interview
vous dites on n'apprend rien il propose
une nouvelle méthode qui
lé pouvoir d'achat la première chose
qu'il faut faire c'est réduire
massivement les cotisations sociales
pour faire en sorte que celles et ceux
qui travaillent puissent gagner mieux
leur vie c'est la première mesure
appréciée des mesures pour des personnes
et des situations qui sont particulières
liées à celles ou tél
oui d'accord mais c'est pas que ça il
faut faire en sorte qu'on revalorise le
travail que ceux qu'ils aillent bosser
puisse bosser avec le sentiment qu'ils
gagnent correctement leur vie or
aujourd'hui on a des compatriotes qui
s'y disent je me lève tous les matins
pour qatar s'emballe autres s emballe
par mois et moi j'ai envie de mieux et
gagner ma vie pour vous il fallait pas
une aide ponctuelle la face à cette
montée des prix qui ont les seins
d'abord il faut massivement faire en
sorte que nos compatriotes qui vont
bosser tous les matins gagnent
correctement l'ordre sur la nouvelle
méthode justement qu'est ce que vous en
pensez cette idée donc
présenté par emmanuel macron à la presse
que des dernières régionales samedi
d'associer les syndicats les
associations les élus locaux des
français tereos je serai avant les
grands je serais à votre place je ferais
un article dans votre journal en dix ans
mais il nous l'a déjà fait combien de
fois cette histoire penser la même chose
que le grand dax ginn jaune que la
coulée tirage au sort
et c est 5 fois je rappelle qu'en plus
de ça derrière ça c'est
l'expression grosso modo un ancien
parlementaire arrêts face et il a débuté
chez lui vous sortez de quelques mois de
campagne électorale en général quand on
sort de campagne étoiles on est plus
intelligent parce que on s'est imprégné
des détentions et des problématiques du
pays et on leur dit oui pour écouter
les dangers quand j'étais pris en main
jean de france nous avons fait la loi
sur la mobilité
j'ai aucun problème et une compétence
technique évidente depuis qu'elle est
première mini c'est ce qu'elle a parlé
avec vos présidents de région non elle
se présente dans ma région comme vous le
savez est parachuté dans une
circonscription du calvados mais mais
non on m'appelle eu l'occasion de
s'exprimer mon aura je pense que carole
delga qui à l'heure actuelle présente
dans les yeux de france a déjà eu une
conversation avec elle je crois qu il
est prévu qu'on soit assez rapidement
pour évoquer les sujets qui sont des
sujets extrêmement important pour les
régions dans les prochains mois et la
france justement vous avez souvent dit
il faut que les élus locaux soit mieux
associé à la politique du gouvernement
est ce que cette nouvelle méthode c'est
pas une manière d'associer des immenses
dont on a besoin c'est d'un grand vent
de liberté locale c'est un grand ventes
d'e santé centralisation c'est un grand
vent d'automne de régionalisation de
faire comme tous les autres pays
européens fait un c'est aussi un peu ça
la transformation la bureaucratie la
transformation de la deux du pays sa
capacité est très actif d'innover de
porter des solutions de proximité
elle se fera si on croit si on a
confiance dans les collectivités locales
comment - en priant de région je crée un
dispositif qui vient au secours des
entreprises fondamentalement sa demie
quand des problématiques de trésorerie
parce qu'ils n'ont pas été payés par un
client parce qu'un marché à l'export qui
s'est tari j'ai sauvé 535 entreprises en
normandie représentant quinze mille
emplois 85 % d'entre elles sont encore
en vie de trois ans plus tard mais ce
genre de solution ça n'est possible que
si ça se sait l'oca ça veut dire que si
vous êtes conviés dans le cas de ce
conseil national de leur fondation vous
n'irez pas j'suis jure bien entendu je
veux pas mais je ne crois absolument pas
au tour de passe-passe en plus j'avais
bien vu coco ses nerfs enfin bon bref
c'est quand même le c'est de la com avec
des câbles comme ça un dernier mot sur
les collectivités sur la question des
finances puisque ça aussi ça fait partie
de vos revendications est ce que vous
redoutez une contribution accrue des
collectivités puisque emmanuel macron a
dit qu'il fallait résorber la question
de la dette du déficit laurent saint
martin qui était le rapporteur général
du budget jusqu'à maintenant parler
d'une limitation des dépenses à hauteur
de 10 milliards pour les collectivités
est ce que vous craignez un retour des
contrats de cahors par exemple écouter
les seuls si on regarde les comptes des
administrations publiques
les seules structures qui ont réduit les
déficits et l'endettement ce sont les
collectivités locales donc elles sont
gérées sérieusement solidement la
question qui va se poser très rapidement
c'est que si vous prenez cette mesure là
vous n'aurez plus aucun d'investissement
local avec la hausse des coupes la
hausse des marchés où on voit beaucoup
de collectivités aujourd'hui
renoncer reportés à des projets si en
plus de ça vous les assécher opposition
d'une chose c'est que l'économie va
encore un peu plus s'arrêter dernier
point sur les annonces des manuels macro
ont fait samedi matin la réforme des
retraites qui aboutirait en 2023 c'est
un bon timing pour vous
écouter vous allez ce temps
ils lancent des trucs on sais même pas
quoi ce à quoi ça correspond pas enfin
on a eu une campagne présidentielle qui
a été totalement saborder de sa volonté
il a commencé expliqué 65 puis 64 puis
voilà donc là il ans quelque chose je ne
peux pas pas à quelqu'un qui globalement
n'a rien dit de sérieux solide construit
sur aucun projet ce qui veut dire qu'au
bout du compte on va être dans un avec
un risque démocratique absolument majeur
d'un côté des mélenchonistes haineux à
l'assemblée nationale en résonance avec
une partie du pays qui compte est
clairement le modèle 2 économie sociale
de marché et donc là la question
démocratique dans le pays risque d'être
un vrai sujet et notamment au moment de
la réforme des retraites est-ce que ça
législatives vont pas se résumer
finalement en affrontements entre la
majorité présidentielle
non parce que moi je disais à votre
consoeur un instant que quand je me je
vais soutenir les candidats aux
législatives en normandie je suis
aujourd'hui convaincu que nous aurons
plus de candidats de la droite et du
centre et lui que nous n'en avons eu en
2017 on a un très bon accueil les gens
ont bien compris qu'il fallait que
l'assemblée nationale représente la
france avec des députés enraciné on a eu
des députés marcheurs qui ont été
pendant cinq ans aux abonnés totalement
absent c'est incroyable j'ai jamais vu
ça quoi députés qu'ils ne sont
absolument pas occupé de leur territoire
de leur circonscription de la relation
que les élus locaux
n'ont même pas l'effort de tenir des
permanences à des rebonds ne pas
respecter ce qui le rend free confiance
vous pensez que vous aurez plus d'une
centaine de députés je dis que je ne dis
pas que je sais pas combien aulnoye mais
tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'on en demande y on en aura plus en
2022 qu'on en avait un de mes vous ne
craignez pas que le front anti mélenchon
favorise justement les candidats la
république en main c'est logique ressent
dans tous les cas c'est peut-être le jeu
que joue la majorité présidentielle
parce que le meilleur est pauvre en
taille c'est celui ci mais moi ce que je
dis c'est qu'il faut pas que les modèles
macro et tous les pouvoirs et que pour
ça il faut l'obliger à dialoguer ou
saillie à françois mitterrand qui avait
une très jolie formule en 2008 où il
avait dit ça n'est pas bon pour la
france quand un seul parti a tous les
pouvoirs eh bien je dis aux français
c'est la même chose il faut obliger le
pouvoir au dialogue à la discussion et à
la construction de solutions qui soient
des solutions de bon sens mais
républicains ne donnerons pas de
consignes de vote habituel la majorité
présidentielle et la nue pour vous
est-ce que vous en donnerai ou est ce
que pour vous majorité présidentielle
est nul c'est la même chose écoutez on
va d'abord régler le premier tour et
après je vous donne en vous m'appellerez
le dimanche je vous donnerai ma position
j'ai très bien ce que je vais faire mais
je chercherai 9 mai parce que ça vous
donnera le plaisir de me revoir la
semaine prochaine
dernière question oui le groupe que vous
appelez de vos voeux est ce qu'il peut
il ce qu'il pourra si la part de
emmanuel macron n'a pas la majorité
absolue à l'assemblée être sur certains
textes forces de la suisse il doit
l'être de la majorité doit l'être en
tout il faut refonder l'école il faut
qu'on soit en capacité de pousser le
gouvernement à refonder l'école je
posais cette question aux écoles
d'ingénieurs aux directeurs des écoles
d'ingénieurs de normandie la semaine
dernière sur dix est dix enseignants
m'ont dit les petits ukrainiens étaient
meilleurs en match aller les petits
français et alors les directeurs
d'écoles d'ingénieurs mon 10mai
présidence et pas simplement les petites
chroniques sont meilleurs que les élèves
que les petits français c'est tous les
élèves étrangers que nous accueillons
dans nos écoles d'ingénieurs qui sont
meilleurs et même ceux qui ont un bac de
pays en général qu'on regarde avec
condescendance iep les pays d'afrique
les pays du maghreb etc ils ont des
niveaux de maths nettement supérieur
aux français
mais là encore on est dans la com et
dans la foutaise c'est une option une
heure une heure et demie c'est pas ça le
sujet comment un pays comme la france
puisse avoir laissé se dégrader autant
les mathématiques et ne plus obliger les
mathématiques à partir de la première
quand on veut réindustrialiser un pays
il nous faut des ingénieurs et pour ça
il faut faire des maths vous faites
confiance au nouveau ministre de
l'éducation pour ce chantier jeu j'en
sais rien je ne connais pas un dernier
mot sur l'avenir pour le coup au delà de
la droite
du centre est ce que vous redoutez une
recomposition à droite notamment autour
des deux cibles que vous connaissez bien
puisqu'il est élu de votre région est ce
qu'il va séduire une partie de la droite
avec l'affaiblissement des répulsifs
vous nous aviez expliqué ou quoi
j'imagine je vous avais dû dire comme
tout le monde que les députés
républicains ou de centre-droit aller
massivement rejoindre l' horizon les
autres en marche vous avez vu est
quasiment une personne bon je sais qu'en
sus lui aura personne après pourquoi
voudriez vous qu'après ces députés s'est
glissée opéré non ce qu'il faut c'est
sûr pour nous et tout cela ils sont dans
la majorité présidentielle
ils sont marché voilà après ça on est
dans la nuance bon
nous pour nous la question elle est
assez simple au lendemain des
législatives
c'est d'abord remettre du carburant dans
le moteur c'est à dire prendre le temps
de la construction d'un projet politique
moderne intégrant les grandes
transformations de la société française
nous courons pas derrière l'extrême
droite tous les matins et bâtissant
quelque chose qui puisse être compris
par tous ces français qui depuis
plusieurs années s'interroge sur qui on
est voilà c'est ça jugé est ce que le
sujet ça va être la question d'aligner 2
qui va succéder à christian jacob et c
est ce que selon la personne et le
profil du successeur de christian jacob
vous interrogerez sur le fait de rester
répulsion on va d'abord terminer les
élections législatives après on aura
largement le temps d'évoquer toutes ces
questions là mais clairement la question
de la ligne politique pourra s'adresser
à la france qui croit en économie
sociale de marché qui je l'espère est
encore
majoritaire aujourd'hui me semble
d'abord et avant tout sujet
[Musique]
vous posez des questions je ne rentre
pas dans ces questions aujourd'hui
d'abord on a une priorité ces élections
législatives quand même des questions
les plus à droite on verra bien ce que
disent les uns et des autres et on vous
invitera à ce moment là aussi c'est vrai
ça fera deux fois fin deux habitations
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin regarder une de la
dépêche avec les sels ce sont les
législatives le compte à rebours c'est à
la une de votre jeu ça marche les
candidats tyrol belga donc dans sa
région
[Rires]
les socialistes contre l'allemagne bien
sûr est là
j'espère qu'elle incarnera la voix de la
raison de la laïcité enfin bref le
l'héritage de blum à mitterrand et la
reconstruction du ps a coûté comment le
ps peut tomber si bas
merci à me morain merci beaucoup d'avoir
été notre invité
[Musique]